okay today
it's all about clean fresh zingy flavors
and speed
a few years ago i traveled around
cambodia thailand vietnam and malaysia
learning all i could from the chefs over
there
and i really fell in love with all their
food i brought back those influences to
my home kitchen
and i've been incorporating them into my
cooking ever since so
get ready for some cracking recipes here
on my ultimate southeast asian dishes
if you want a pick-me-up first thing in
the morning forget a double expresso
i think chili gives you an even bigger
boost and it's incredible in my
breakfast fruit salad
for lunch it's my take on a traditional
noodle soup with fresh clams
for dessert banana fritters bursting
with flavor
and one of the best things about
southeast asian food is it's easy
and a great way to get your kids cooking
jack
to prove it my son jack's joining me in
the kitchen to cook up some sticky spicy
chicken wings
because it's your favorite serve with
fragrant thai rice and stir-fry green
beans with soy and peanut dressing
this is my ultimate southeast asian food
breakfast
lunch and dinner
right one of my favorites it's a tangy
fruit salad and it's for breakfast would
you believe
start off with a chili now
give it a little rub so
you can hear those seeds being released
get your knife and come all the way down
turn it over and just slice it into four
and then finely chop that chilli
i want this salad slightly hot so i'm
going to use all the chili
but half the seeds the seeds are where
the heat is so
the less you use the milder your dish
nicely chopped
next one my favorite paste tamarind
paste
this is quite tart quite sour but it's a
wonderful compliment to the sweetness of
the fruit and it goes brilliantly well
with a chilli
palm sugar and this is where it sweetens
up
the dressing because it enriches it then
the zest
and the juice of a lime cut it into
quarters
and then twist the lime to maximize
on all that juice out now to finish that
dressing off
some toasted peanuts
get the pan nice and hot
a little touch of salt that'll help dry
roast the peanuts even quicker
make sure you get a really nice dark
color on those peanuts
because it will really transform that
dressing to crush your roasted nuts the
mess-free way
simply wrap them in a clean cloth and
use a rolling pin
or a pan to bash them crush
that's the hard bit done now
for the fruit and here's an easy way to
prep a pineapple
pineapple take off the top
take off the bottom
and stand it up use the corner of your
knife and follow down
basically like shaving the pineapple
don't worry about these little spikes
there
the secret behind doing it this way is
not losing half the pineapple
there's nothing wrong with a few brown
bits it's all good fiber
slice the pineapple in half and then
slice down
each quarter slice across
and chop delicious
pineapple chunks next apples and pears
diced then to give a lovely fresh light
note
the seeded cucumber i don't want the
seeds in the fruit salad
the cucumber seeds will make it very
watery and dilute the strength for that
wonderful chili in there
cucumber in for some sweetness
delicious mango just slice it nicely
get your dressing and just drizzle that
over the fruit salad
in the secret of a good fruit salad
is not drowning in the dressing but
really make sure that you've got that
nice coating on all
the fruits don't worry about just having
for breakfast because this is the kind
of tangy fruit salad you can have
for lunch a healthy snack in the
afternoon but it transforms
a traditional fruit salad into something
really delicious
spicy fruit salad with a kick of chili
trust me it's an incredible breakfast
and a guaranteed pick me up in the
morning
[Music]
next i'm showing you a sensational
southeast asian lunch and dinner
here's a closer look at some of the key
ingredients you'll need to buy
to make them
first up a southeast asian essential
lemongrass
buy it as a paste dry or powdered but i
love it
fresh best most of the flavor is in the
thick bowl bend
which can be either crushed or chopped
to add flavor to a dish
wrapped in clim film it will keep up to
10 days in the fridge
lemongrass is central to southeast asian
foods especially thai
and i'm using it in my lunch and dinner
recipes
[Music]
another south east asian staple is
tamarind made from the fruit from the
tamarind tree
biotin powder cake or paste form
it's sweet and sour at the same time and
gives brown sauces
and worcestershire sauce their distinct
flavors
i've already used it in my fruit salad
now i'm going to put it in my chicken
marinade for dinner too
[Applause]
lastly is clams they're prized from all
over southeast asia
but the most common types to buy in
britain are beautiful plump venus clams
sweet tasty mineral clams and razor
clams
which are shaped like an old-fashioned
cutthroat razor
clams are fantastic raw baked in sauces
or in soups like this one i'm making for
lunch
there's one rule only prepare live ones
so discard any that don't open during
[Applause]
[Music]
cooking
all over southeast asia you find people
cooking and eating the huge bowls
of delicious noodle soups it's a very
simple dish but the variations you get
are extraordinary different meats
different fish
and even different dumplings but what i
love most about noodle soup
is the fact there's a complete meal
carbs protein
and vegetables in one big bowl of
happiness
for my ultimate southeast asian lunch
i'm showing you one of my favorites
spicy clam and noodle soup followed by
sweet moorish banana
and coconut fritters for dessert
first up my dessert banana fritters
take your bananas and to get them really
nice and soft
just rub banana sip together
flour and baking powder
sugar into the flour
then add coconut for texture and a pinch
of salt
sounds strange in the dessert but it
works brilliantly especially
with the fritters makes the batter nice
and crisp start
crushing
and use the back of the fork and just
push it against the side of the bowl
and then once you've mixed that
through i'm gonna make that mix now
slightly fragrant
with some lime zest
now the lime just really
elevates the sort of richness and the
denseness of the banana
a couple of clin film so it doesn't get
a skin on top sit that in the fridge for
15 minutes
as the banana fritter mixture rests i'm
getting on with my broth for the noodle
and clam soup
fish stock is the base bring that up to
the boil
now to take that broth to another level
in with chopped shallots
fresh ginger add a whole chili seeds and
all
i actually quite like it spicy
adjust chop once
and into the broth bring it up to the
ball
and let it simmer galangal it's sort of
almost like a softer version of ginger
slightly milder
you can use galangal paste but i prefer
the fresh stuff
the stems for coriander we'll finish the
broth with the
heads and that's what endeared me to the
southeast asian style of cooking
across my travels there was there's no
waste in
lime leaves for me one of my favorites
incredibly pungent strong full of flavor
very acidic
but gives a really nice aroma to the
broth
just tear them in now
the lemongrass so the secret here
that's where all the flavor is right at
the very end so you take the back of the
knife
and you just bash the lemongrass
it's all that flavor is going to run out
in seconds
that's the base of the broth done the
longer you leave it
the more intense it gets whilst the
broth infuses
soak your rice noodles in boiling water
for 10 minutes just enough time to fry
your fritters
the batter now is ready use a metal
spoon to drop the batter
to the bottom of the pan they hit that
oil
they puff up that's why it's important
to put your spoon into the oil
so the mixture runs off and creates this
lovely little
fritter
then gently fry get a slotted spoon
nice and carefully turn them over
smell of that lime is extraordinary
fry for two to three minutes as they
start floating
it signifies the fact that they're
cooked off with a gas
and just let them drain are those
beauties
lovely sprinkling when they're hot
with the sugar actually sticks to them
they're done ready to go the last job
before serving
the clams never be scared of cooking
shellfish
the most important rule is if they are
slightly
opened a millimeter discard it
make sure muscles clams are always tight
cook the clams for just three to five
minutes or until they're all open
bring that up to the boil and this is
where we finish the broth
touch of fish sauce a little sprinkle of
sugar
drain your noodles into the bowl
for added texture some delicious bean
sprouts
get your lime fresh squeeze and lime
juice in
beautiful literally as the stock comes
up to the boil
the clams open automatically so they
cook
beautifully the flavor from inside the
clam
has enhanced the broth
smell is incredible the clams cooked
finish with fresh coriander and serve
there you have
a perfect lunch a delicious spicy
clam noodle with an amazing banana
fritter
my spicy clam noodle soup and banana and
coconut fritters
made in minutes and proof you only need
to travel as far as your kitchen
to get the taste of southeast asia
[Music]
when i was traveling in southeast asia
one of the things that really struck me
was how seriously
they take meal times family and friends
all sit down together
to eat catch up and have a great time
it's a really big part of their daily
life
so how it works is they put a whole load
of different dishes in the middle of the
table and everyone helps themselves
i love this way of eating it's very
social and really relaxed so
i've adopted it here in our house too
i also like the family to share the
cooking
and today my son jack's joining me in
the kitchen
he's got a vested interest in learning
to cook sticky spiced chicken wings
jack here's a hand please bub why
because it's your favorite yeah chicken
wings
okay all right let's start off with the
marinade tamarind paste in first
all that into there all of that yeah
okay
good so two tablespoons of palm sugar
please is that like heated sugar
um it's a really good question it's a
natural palm sugar
and it's perfect for marinades how many
wings do you think you've eaten so far
at the age of 13. oh i eat
probably 50 a year 50 years yeah
something like that a nice sprinkle of
chili flakes depends how hot you like
them
oh i love them hot hot don't forget the
girls you know they start complaining
when you get them too hot how come you
love hot food
um i don't know i truly love hot food
so in there we've got palm sugar
tamarind paste
chili flakes some garlic one nice
tablespoon
of fish sauce please this is looking
really good
isn't it and then a couple of
tablespoons of oil the marinade
in how nice little taste
not your finger jack
that's really good right wings in get
your hands in there and start
rubbing in the marinade please okay so
the
secret now is to coat the chicken wings
and all that marinade
yeah yeah how long do you leave them in
here
do you know what the longer the better
cover that with limp film wash your
hands
excellent good job
ideally marinate your wings overnight
but half an hour will be enough to get
the flavors going
[Applause]
right so they've marinated now if you
take the tray out people
bottom one thank you and then we're
gonna put some tinfoil on there thank
you
so hold that in half
it stops them from sticking and that'll
stop
the wings from burning so from there get
them really dipped in
that marinade and try and get the wing
like that and just sort of
scoop it look like that so i get that
really nice glaze on there
and then just yeah
so that garlic will roast and i got all
those wings
usually done i can make then ready for
the oven
170 25 to 30 minutes yep
good man excellent
nice it's hot wings are in
right to go with my ultimate southeast
asian dinner
rice cooked in homemade thai green curry
paste
for the easy green curry paste roughly
chop coriander
lemongrass green chilies
lime leaf shallots garlic
and ginger a glug of oil
and blitz the paste takes minutes to
make
but it'll keep for up to 10 days if
covered with oil and stored in a sealed
jar
in the fridge to awaken the flavors
lime roll to release the juice
next season with salt and pepper and
blend into a smooth paste
heat the paste until aromatic add in
cooled or leftover rice i love using
fragrant jasmine rice
but your standard long grain rice is
great too
when thoroughly heated through serve
thai green curry paste is so easy to
make so with rice like this
it's incredible but simply add to
chicken
fish or veg to create a fantastic meal
in minutes
right now for the green beans beans in
uh bring the water to the ball what's
the first thing i should put in there
beans
salt salt so nice pinch of salt in there
yeah so make an amazing dressing two
nine tablespoons
yeah of a crunchy peanut butter please
why is it crunchy
it'll give it texture and it'll be nice
and sort of
chunky green beans in okay got the rice
green beans we're gonna blotch them for
two two and a half minutes
what does blanching actually mean
blanching means sort of part cooking
okay i'm gonna blanch them in boiling
water yeah and then finish them
in the pan use the back of the spoon a
little bit easier
a teaspoon of brown sugar and she goes
nice is that a little bit too thick
maybe
yeah it is let's put a little touch more
soy sauce in there let it down
yeah yeah that's better a little touch
of vinegar nice
i'm gonna get a pan on now put my beans
so a little taste did you taste it it's
so good
oh man hmm wow
so if you got the garlic like that i'm
going to slice the garlic down like this
keep the knife nice and flat that way
you'll slice through it
but take your time don't worry about the
speed and technique right first
just cut it in half okay your fingers
good
and then lay the flat side down so it's
nice and sturdy and that nail there
it's not out like that it's just guiding
the knife so you can never cut yourself
like that
good i'll drain the beans
nice a little tablespoon
of oil get the pan nice and hot
i'm gonna throw the garlic in people
good nice
mmm so fine smell that already is that
lovely
so give that a little toss
so when you toss it push it down push
away
and pull back okay have a little go
push it down gently take your time
nice so push down
and pull back up that's it nice so it's
getting nice
and golden brown green beans i've
drained
and they go in now to the garlic
combination of green beans okay with the
rice
oh there's none of that oh wow
i want you now to spoon the dressing
release
and she goes nice how delicious
does that look wow what's daddy's policy
at home no waste
no waste no waste but now
smell that now oh wow
it doesn't smell like green beans it
smells like what is this oh thanks
how nice is that lovely amazing
right
that's the rice that's the green beans
[Music]
now i want you to sprinkle some toasted
sesame seeds on top please nice and
generous with a sesame seed i'll give
the beans a little bit of a crunch
now all that's left
for your favorites to come out don't
those beans smell amazing
jack look at those beauties one for me
one for you three for me one for you
now i'd like you to sprinkle some spring
onions
on top please nice and generous
you transformed a very cheap and
cheerful chicken wing
yeah all right let me take them over
please do not drop them okay
jack let's go nice
this is my ultimate simple southeast
asian dinner
sticky spicy chicken wings thai green
curry rice
and fantastic beans with chili peanut
dressing guaranteed
to get the fussiest of eaters into
greens
holly tanner ready for jack's wings i
was trying to help myself and pass them
along
chat with some rice peas what about you
guys
how's i know you're allergic to anything
green
how are the beans i've seen you eat more
green beans the last five minutes then
you have them in the last 10 years
they're really nice now i know the
secret you have to put peanut butter on
it are you going to dig into those
chicken wings now
fingers right definitely
oh wow nice very very good very nice
jack
yeah they're tasty great there's no
dainty way of doing this no holly don't
worry about your nail varnish you'll be
fine
oh you're such a lady
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the app
store good luck
you